in I always wanted to ask you this I
remember you did clap back for John role
right which was a fire ants record but
at that time nobody was [ __ ] over John
roll this guy to that weird part of his
career where 50 they had the beef and
people kind of chose size when you ended
up working with 50 on the massacre
did was that like a conversation like
like you did lean back obviously yeah I
was 50 see my kinda guy and I know you
made that clear to everybody I am NOT on
some rat beef [ __ ] but at the time he
was and I'm trying to eat like I was a
starving Lord you know you could have
mad records I still haven't made no
money so my focus was working and like
you know I'll leave those beefs to other
people
but like a lot of times I would find
myself doing records you know for people
and like I would get like that clap back
as an example like it wasn't supposed to
go to him like that
Debbie was so fine that beat I made in
my house the day before I was going to
New York I was going to New York to work
with wait on Janet Jackson and Wyclef
studio I remember just clear as a bell
and that day before PD crack and beanie
sigel steak knives in my house in
Florida I made that beat and I guess um
you know just it never happened like
they just were asleep in the studio
wasn't you know whatever so but that was
meant first I left the next day to New
York and I got the call from like yo I
need something I was like I giving this
beat and it was like a two track and
never got that song never got mixed Wow
yeah like the music of it was just given
like a two track on like a dad tape like
from the crib so remember they eacute it
or whatever that's crazy
weird how like records and though that
it's funny because I think that's when
it like obviously it wasn't like the
biggest hit in the world that that beat
was so hard man it could I used to
cringe in the club when I would hear it
because it was like oh my god it sounds
so thin compared to all if you knew it
was it mastered yeah it wasn't mixed
I'm like Jude making me look bad